CASH.
MARK MORGAN, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
WE ARE NOT ACCUSING BOOKER OF
THAT.
MATT GAETZ REPRESENTS THE STATE
OF FLORIDA IN THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS, AND WE ARE HAPPY TO
HAVE HIM TODAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
IT IS CLEAR IN ORDER TO RESTORE
PUBLIC FAITH IN THE MOST
POWERFUL INSTITUTIONS OF
GOVERNMENT WE HAVE TO KNOW WHAT
HAPPEN HERE.
WHY DON'T WE?
>> WE HAVE NOT HAD THE DIRECTOR
OF NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE LAYOUT
FOR US WHAT WAS IN THE
TRANSCRIPTS TAKEN BY THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE WHERE
THEY INTERVIEWED CLAPPER, WHERE
THEY INTERVIEWED COMEY AND
McCABE AND BRENNAN, AND WE
OUGHT TO HAVE THAT INFORMATION.
>> Tucker: I DID NOT KNOW
THAT.
>> OVER 50 TRANSCRIPTS HAVE BEEN
VOTED OUT OF THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE TO BE
DECLASSIFIED SO THAT WE CAN GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF WHERE THE LIES
EXISTED AND HOW THIS TERRIBLE
INVESTIGATION OCCURRED.
>> Tucker: WHY HAS HE NOT MADE
THEM PUBLIC?
>> FOUR MONTHS WE HAVE BEEN
WAITING, BUT THERE IS A BIGGER
PROBLEM, WE HAVE TO RELY ON THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
IN THE LEADERSHIP OF THAT
COMMITTEE, BECAUSE EVERY MEMBER
OF CONGRESS DOES NOT SEE EVERY
PIECE OF INTELLIGENCE.
I FILED LEGISLATION TODAY, THAT
ADAM SCHIFF NEEDS TO BE REMOVED
FROM THE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE,
BECAUSE A HOW ARE THE REST OF US
SUPPOSED TO BE ABLE TO RELY ON A
MAN WHO YOU JUST SHOWED LIED TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WHEN HE SAID
THAT THERE WAS NOT SPYING, OR
WHEN HE LIED AND SAID THAT THERE
WAS EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION OR
CLEAR EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION?
IF ADAM SCHIFF IS ABLE TO REVIEW
COVERT OPERATIONS AND
INTELLIGENCE COMING AND WE HAVE
TO RELY ON HIS REPRESENTATION,
THE WHOLE SYSTEM IS BROKEN.
IT WOULD BE LIKE PUTTING LORI
LAUGHLIN IN CHARGE OF THE
COLLEGE BOARD.
IT WOULD BE LIKE PUTTING JUSSIE
SMOLLETT IN CHARGE OF THE FBI.
>> Tucker: I HAVE NEVER SEEN A
TONGASS PERSON WITH LOWER
INTEGRITY THAN ADAM SCHIFF, AND
IT IS SHOCKING THAT HE SHARES
THE COMMITTEE.
IS THERE ANY HOPE ON PEELING HIM
FROM THAT?
>> NANCY PELOSI AND THE OTHER
DEMOCRATS HAVE TO FEEL THE
PRESSURE.
THE CONSTITUENTS HAVE TO ASK
THEM HOW THEY WILL MAKE
DECISIONS IN THE BEST INTEREST
OF THE COUNTRY AND THE DISTRICT
IF IT IS ADAM SCHIFF THAT YOU
ARE LISTENING TO YOU TO GET
CHARACTER'S STATIONS AND TO
REPRESENTATION ON THE QUALITY OF
THE INTELLIGENCE AND WHETHER IT
SHOULD JUSTIFY CONGRESSIONAL
ACTION.
>> Tucker: I WANT TO EXPLAIN
THE NAME OF THE ACT, THE PENCIL
ACT.
>> FOR THE FAVORITE PENCIL,
TUCKER.
>> Tucker: THAT IS EXACTLY
RIGHT.
YOU STRIKE THE HALLS OF
CONGRESS, IS THERE ANY DEMOCRAT
THAT BEHIND THE SCENES COMING
YOU DO NOT HAVE TO REVEAL NAMES,
AGREES WITH YOU?
A COMMITTEE OF THIS SENSITIVE
SHOULD NOT BE SHARED BY ADAM
SCHIFF?
>> THERE ARE DEMOCRATS IN
CONGRESS WHO FEEL BETRAYED.
BECAUSE LIKE THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY THEY WERE TOLD THAT
THERE WAS ACTUAL EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION.
THAT THIS WOULD HAPPEN.
AND A LOT OF THOSE DEMOCRATS
WENT OUT ON A LIMB IN THE
CAMPAIGN AND PROMISE THEIR
VOTERS THAT THIS EVIDENCE WOULD
BE TURNED UP.
NOW WE KNOW THAT THE WHOLE DEAL
WAS FAKE.
IT WAS A LIE.
AND I THINK THAT A LOT OF THE
NARRATIVE HAS BEEN A COVER-UP
FOR THE FACT THAT UNDER THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION, OUR
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY GOT SO
UNDER THE LEVELS THAT THEY
ALLOWED POLITICAL OPPOSITION
RESEARCH TO JUSTIFY SOMETHING
THAT SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN IN THIS
COUNTRY.
YOU ARE RIGHT, IT SHOULD NEVER
HAPPEN FROM EITHER SIDE.
BUT THE ONLY WAY WE CAN GET TO
THE SOLUTION IS A FULLY REFORM
THE PROCESS THAT ALLOWS SECRET
COURTS TO ABRIDGE OUR RIGHTS.
>> Tucker: THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT WAS SIGNED UP FOR WITHOUT
THINKING THROUGH IT AFTER 9/11,
CORRECT?
>> YES, BUT I THINK WE WILL
RETHINK IT.
AT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT TO
KNOW HOW WE GOT HERE AND THEY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
NEVER HERE AGAIN.
>> Tucker: HOW CAN YOU HAVE A
SECRET COURT IN A DEMOCRACY?
>> YOU DO NOT KNOW WHAT THE
JUDGES BELIEVE, AND THE OPINIONS
ARE NEVER MADE PUBLIC.
SO EVEN 20 YEARS LATER YOU ARE
NOT ABLE TO ASCERTAIN WHAT THE
DOCTRINE WAS THAT WAS GETTING
THE MOST POWERFUL TOOLS IN OUR
GOVERNMENT TO BE TURNED AGAINST
OUR CITIZENS IN THE ABSENCE OF